hello st. Louis we're all having an
enjoyable free day during the 2015
Norway chess festival and we're in the
Science Park your name again please my
name is Ellen Bell and tell us about the
park where we are right now you're right
now you're at the science factory it's
cold here in Sunnis and which is the
city next to stavanger and we are a
combination of a science center NM you
see and where we're going to tell the
industrial history of the region but we
all want two children to take part and
be active and experiencing so it's all
very interactive museum compared to
others well precisely i just love the
indirect way you get to touch and feel
and move your hands and try to
understand whether it be gravitational
forces or the planets or anything it's
just wonderful I'm really impressed by
what you've done well thank you very
much I'm glad to you to hear that well
we're really I feel it and yet today you
staged a chess tournament in your part
how did that come about we did it was
actually no HS that contacted us last
year because they've got our one of the
big important things here is to have a
school tournament and encourage the
children to learn chess early so they
found it very suitable to be here we
also got similar thoughts and even the
mathematics for us is very important
subject chess and mathematics Yahoo goes
hand-in-hand it's a contacted us then
and then we had one last year and then
we just had 150 children through today
which has been amazing well exactly I
saw so many and it'll all ages I mean
very very young children with their
little apps there are chess apps all the
way to some of the champions that were
earned diplomas and trophy so very
impressive outing yeah and some of them
you know yes some of them are actually
only six years and they competed for the
first time others are 11 and 12 and
they've actually become Norwegian
champions previously in their special
teams not with the school teams yeah and
it's amazing you know you have 150
children usually we have so much noise
here and we love noise we want it to be
noisy but then when they say it ready
set go you know
the house is just quiet and that's
amazing to see how discipline they are
and how much into the chest they are
wonderful thank you for sharing your
thoughts and being with this has been
really really a delightful afternoon my
pleasure thank you for coming